i was born and raised in the detroit
area on the other side of eight mile
about five miles from the city center um
and also craig my co-producer and
co-cinematographer also from the area so
there was that that started the whole
conversation around the office of what
to do next and what was happening to our
hometown our parents both still live in
the area much of our family
and um so
that there was that was the initial
impetus was a conversation that happened
at the office uh to make the film and
also uh i'm the daughter of a a
manufacturer so my father had a family
business
that made parts for the auto industry so
i feel like i'm a daughter of american
manufacturing in the sense that it put
me through college and i didn't realize
what all of that meant when i when i was
growing up but over the years i've
thought more and more about what's
happening to our manufacturing base so
the combination of those interests
really was the impetus but once we went
filming in october 2009 we brought our
cameras there uh just to see what we'd
find just on a whim we stayed with our
parents you know brought our bro brought
tony hartman our cinematographer and we
started filming and we filmed for three
days and i have filmed all over the
world saudi arabia and cuba and malawi
etc and it was not only the most
cinematic place
which i was under my nose all these
years but it was the most cinematic
place i never brought a camera which was
startling and just the urgency of the
way people spoke to us there was a real
urgency and it didn't feel like a local
story so much we felt like something
bigger and so we basically decided there
i would get back to new york we'd cut
together a little trailer went to
sundance that year
with another film and would finish
screenings of 12th in delaware and we
would start showing on an ipod our
trailer and we raised the first 120 000
at the festival to start shooting so we
were very uh ready to go detroiters kind
of had a wall around initially just
because there was a lot of people coming
from the outside and and doing pieces
such as uh that the nightline piece uh
another local person came by and found
the one person hunting raccoons and and
put that on as a story so the
low-hanging fruit very much so yeah and
so um it took a tremendous amount of
time to build those relationships
especially with the mayor's office uh
what what you saw in the one scene was
it was basically the result of six
months of every single day checking in
and hopefully hoping that we would
actually get get access so
you know i think that
detroiters have seen the writing on the
wall for a very long time and i think
they were eager to tell the story but
they wanted to make sure that you know
we would
do an appropriate job you know with with
that there's this real insider outsider
us versus them mentality is a real chip
on the shoulder of detroiters um and and
there's also there's a lot more than
that there's a lot of affection for
their their city and so
they were a funny bunch in terms of
subjects nobody was dying to be filmed i
mean the best characters in documentary
we found don't really care if you're
there or not and they're the best
characters and documentaries are exactly
the same if the camera is rolling or not
the same there's the new creative class
that are just showing up and there's
lifelong detroiters and and those two
populations are are headed for a
collision i think there's really no
interaction between the two groups right
now um the people on the porch talk
about urban farming and drop the tomato
i mean they're talk you know the urban
farming is something talked about in the
new uh you know arrival you know that
community for the last two years and a
lot of detroiters have been out of that
conversation completely and that scene
just shows the disconnect that you know
something that's been widely talked
about and they had you know no idea
whatsoever and in you know they live in
the neighborhoods where the urban
farming would take you know would
actually take place so i think that uh
detroit you know with the
the the rival of the new um creative
class is wonderful but they're going to
have to figure out a way to integrate in
order to obviously be any type of
successful as a city as a whole
this is our contribution to
there seems to be a real moment of
national anxiety in the country right
now there's a lot of talk of you know is
american exceptionalism true or false
are we
are we on decline or is the is the
decline inevitable
are we no longer great have we lost our
edge all of these questions that people
seem that they want to talk about i
think if we made this film five years
ago um it wouldn't be in released in 50
cities and this wouldn't be happening i
think that this is our contribution to
this conversation our cinematic
contribution to a conversation about
which way this country is going to go
forward it's also i hope that it's
reflects and reminds people the
importance of having industry in this
country
and that we don't just have to keep
mindlessly and blindly
selling the store you know and i think
that without corporate america coming to
the table in some kind of in a real way
we couldn't even get any of the
corporations that we spoke to in this
film that we profiled to speak to us at
all
so that's a bad sign i think there
really needs to be uh some a collective
conversation about how we're going to um
not just keep uh pushing the middle
class and the working poor and just keep
farming all these jobs out there's got
to be a way these companies can continue
to make a profit and not just remove all
the jobs
because there's no industry or sector to
replace them